breaking news in the last few minutes
nasa's engineers have recommended to the
flight director that the artemis one
moon mission should be cancelled it has
been due to launch in just under three
hours two and a half hours if the launch
is canceled it'll be the second time it
was cancelled remember on monday they
scrubbed it they didn't cancel it they
postponed it then they were looking to
obviously today there was a two-hour
launch window from about 7 17 our time
so in about two and a half hours and it
was meant to launch then but we're
hearing that the launch crew have said
that they recommend a no-go decision
this is a tweet from um
nasa that's the latest from them let me
get this up here so i can read it so
during tanking of the artemis one
mission so that's the um the first of
these artemis
rockets that are meant to go to the moon
um a leak developed in the supply side
of the 8-inch quick disconnect while
attempting to transfer fuel to the
rocket attempts to fix it so far have
been unsuccessful stand by for updates
so that's basically what we're doing
we're standing by that was 37 minutes
ago
these are live picks so let me talk you
through um what's happened basically
as the launch team started fueling this
rocket for liftoff it's a test flight
remember no astronauts are on board so
they've got to get this right before
they put astronauts on this is
astronomers one artemis ii will have
astronauts artemis three will take
astronauts to the moon but this artemis
one going up round the moon and back
it sprang um another hazardous leak on
saturday as they began fueling it for
liftoff this is the second attempt now
second time this week they started
loading nearly a million gallons of fuel
into this this 98 meter rocket that's
322
feet it's the most powerful ever built
by nasa monday you'll remember that was
scrubbed that's the term they use no go
monday's attempt was halted it was a bad
engine sensor and then leaking fuel as
well now as the sun came up in florida
today an over-pressure alarm sounded and
the tanking operation it was briefly
halted
but no damage happened and so they
started fueling again
minutes later however hydrogen fuel
started leaking from the engine section
at the bottom of the rocket they stopped
the operation
engineers scrambled they tried to plug
what they believe
is a gap around
a seal
and then
obviously countdown clocks ticking
because they have a specific window two
hour window two hours on saturday to get
it ready um and we are waiting now to
see if they've managed to deal with that
leaky seal
this is the moment
little earlier when the team realized
that something was wrong
got an update on the liquid hydrogen
loading they are in stop flow
at the moment
there was a leak detected
in the engine cavity
went up to eight percent that put it in
automatic
revert for the liquid hydrogen flow
rockets in a safe configuration
looking at the path forward
okay let's go to martha kellner hi
martha you're with us martha's on cocoa
beach she's at um in cape canaveral in
florida and martha what are we hearing
yeah there's hundreds of people here on
cocoa beach in cape canaveral there's
also people lining the roadsides and the
waterways across this part of florida
hoping uh to see you might be able to
see just over my right shoulder the nasa
headquarters is there that's where the
launch pad of artemis one is
these people are likely though to be
disappointed in the coming minutes it
does seem like nasa is poised to once
again cancel this scheduled launch of
the artemis one rocket they have a
launch window between 217 um and 417
local time for this rocket to take off
but we have been told that there is a
hydrogen leak
in an area inside the rocket that is
difficult to access from the launch pad
so it seems like there's going to be a
lot of disappointed people here once
again there was a launch scheduled for
earlier this week on monday which was
also called off um because of problems
on that occasion calling
one of the rockets four engines and so
nasa trying desperately to to try and
rescue this launch window but hopes are
fading fast they have around
20 minutes uh left in this particular to
know whether this window is at all
likely but it does seem that it might be
about to be called off once again
that means that they will then look at
another launch window on tuesday they
may be able to get the rocket away then
if that's not possible if they're not
able to to sufficiently fix this
hydrogen leak in one of the engines the
rocket will then go into what is
effectively a large garage for rockets
to undergo further repairs that means a
potential future launch will be delayed
for a month or more
now
this particular launch the launch of
artemis one uh is uncrewed that means
that there's no actual human beings
going up in this rocket
instead there are four mannequins that
are strapped inside this rocket they
have sensors all over them which will
test the pressure and the idea is that
this rocket which is the most powerful
rocket ever launched from earth
will do rotations of the moon it'll go
as close as 60 miles to the moon's
surface and it will beam images of
craters on the moon uh back to earth
there will then be around a two-year gap
before a crude mission would go up to to
do this similar journey of rotations
around the earth and then by around 2025
the engineers behind artemis one hope
that people will be able to land on the
moon for the first time in five years
but it does seem like
another delay is about to hit this
scheduled mission we're waiting here for
the fight for the final decision from
nasa on this launch window this
afternoon